BRAD TEMPLETON: Welcome
to Authors at Google.
I'm Brad Templeton.
We're here today with Mez Naam,
who has written a new
book called Nexus, nothing
to do with Google.
Yet his talk is going to be
about Google and your brain.
Mez used to be at Microsoft,
where he was a product manager
for Microsoft Outlook.
How many people remember
Microsoft Outlook?
And also instrumental on
Internet Explorer.
But of late he's become a light
in the transhumanist
field, writing books about
what happens when new
technologies actually change
what it means to be human.
He has three books coming
out this year.
One of them is a science-- two
of them, actually, are science
fiction novels, Nexus being the
science fiction novel as
well as a nonfiction novel.
He's here to tell us about it
and some of the ideas that
he's been promoting
in this field.
He also is a guest lecturer at
Singularity University, where
I'm also present, and has been
working on changing the world
for a long time now.
Mez.
[APPLAUSE]
RAMEZ NAAM: Awesome.
All right, thank you, Brad.
Thanks Matt Cutts as well, for
you guys for setting this up.
Yeah, so I have a book
out called Nexus.
I hear that a company, a
technology company in the
Valley has a similar product
or a product
with the same name.
I'm waiting for the co-marketing
dollars.
So just contact me if you're
watching this.
This is a science fiction novel
set in the near future,
2040, which sounds like
a ways in the future.
But it's as far ahead of us
as 1985 was behind us.
That's how close it is.
The premise is that there is a
drug that you can take that's
packaged as a drug.
But it's actually a set of
nanodevices that attach to
your brain and transmit
wirelessly what
your brain is doing.
And so if two or more people
have this, their brains sort
of sync up.
And you get weak telepathy,
is what Corey Doctorow
described it as.
And my protagonists are working
on enhancing this.
They live in San Francisco.
And there are various battles
between a US government agency
that wants it illegal and a
foreign power that may or may
not be using it for
mind control.
So it's a thriller.
it's really fun.
The science in it is as
real as I can make it.
Most of the science in it I
researched for a book I wrote
in 2005 called More Than Human
about the actual science of
augmenting our minds
and bodies.
Now of course, we've seen this
idea of getting data in and
out of the brain in science
fiction for a long time.
We've seen in the Borg in Star
Trek, for instance, where
connectivity of the brain makes
a super-organism that's
very homogeneous.
We've seen it in The Nexus,
where the great American
philosopher, Keanu Reeves, gets
to say I know Kung Fu.
BRAD TEMPLETON: That was
actually called The Matrix.
They haven't renamed it.
RAMEZ NAAM: Oh, sorry.
This film with this guy.
But we've also seen some people
talking about it in
other contexts.
For instance, a certain
technologist here in Silicon
Valley said you can imagine
your brain being
augmented by Google.
You'd think about the question
and Google would whisper an
answer into your ear.
Or maybe Google could
just implant the
answer in your brain.
Sergey has said we'd like to
think about Google being the
third half of your brain.
So I kind of like that idea
of having 1.5 brains.
You could have a bumper sticker
on your car that says
"my other brain is a data
center." As we all know,
Sergey is well on his
way to being an
augmented transhuman already.
So this leads to the question
of, could you have Google in
your brain?
Well I'm a program manager.
So I think about, what the
requirements for this product
if we want to build it?
Well, you want to have
five things, I think.
Data input, you've got to get
data into your brain.
Data output, you've got to get
data out of your brain and
into the machine or the cloud
or other people's brains.
We're going to have to do some
encoding and decoding work,
because the format for this data
is probably not the same
between our machines and
our brains currently.
So we're going to have some
converters in there, some
protocol shifting.
You want multiple data types,
at minimum, text, audio, and
video, and hopefully some other
data types as well.
And of course it has to be safe,
secure, and deployable,
private as well, which might
actually turn out to be the
largest challenges of
this technology.
So of course that sounds
like science fiction.
But what I'm going to tell you
is that very, very, very early
versions of this are possible
now, that we have low
bandwidth, low fidelity
transport of various data
types in and out of the human
brain right now, and that it
is getting better very,
very quickly.
Now why is it getting better.
Who's investing in this?
Is this a Google X project?
Mostly it's not.
It's really being developed
for medical reasons.
There's a large number of deaf
people in the world, 20
million in the US who are
hearing impaired.
Two million of them can't be
helped by normal hearing aids.
They have what's called
sensorineural deafness.
That means the inner ear hair
cells are damaged or
completely gone.
And so they cannot turn sound
waves, vibrations in the air,
into nerve impulses.
There's 1.3 million blind
people in the US.
There's two million paralyzed
people in the US alone.
1 and 1/2 million people with
Parkinson's disease, which is
essentially not exactly
untreatable, but
uncurable right now.
5 and 1/2 million people
with a traumatic brain
injury of some sort.
This is a scan of the brain of
Phineas Gage, a very famous
patient you had a
railroad spike
launched through his head.
He lived through the process but
came out a very different
guy with a different
personality, and modifications
to his attention and
memory and so on,
and not for the better.
So at least 10 million people
in the US who are candidates
for this technology, and really
probably close to a
quarter billion people in the
world who suffer from these
problems as well.
So that's the motive.
So how does this work?
Well, there's a long history
of this technology.
It goes back to 1870 when two
German physicians had this
crazy idea of an experiment to
show that the nervous system
was electrical.
It was so crazy that the
university, the University of
Berlin, , wouldn't allow
them to perform it.
So instead they used Hitzig's
dining room table.
They put a dog to sleep
with anesthesia.
And then they electrically
stimulated parts of its brain
and found that they
could cause its
paws to move on demand.
So that was the first indication
that the nervous
system is electrical.
We really got the first proof
that it's not just muscle
motion but actual cognition is
electrochemical in the 1950s
thanks to this man,
Wilder Penfield.
He was a neurosurgeon who worked
on a number of things.
But among them was surgery
for epileptics.
Back in that day, and continuing
to today, one of
the techniques used for epilepsy
was called oblation.
What that meant was you did
brain surgery, found the part
| the brain that was sending
out these incorrect signals
leading to epilepsy,
and you cut it out.
Now Penfield wanted
to minimize the
damage to his patients.
So he would electrically
probe the brain
while they were awake.
When he'd find the part of the
brain that was responsible for
the seizures, they would
have a seizure.
So then he would know
to cut out just that
spot and nothing else.
But when he simulated other
parts of the brain, he'd find
that people would suddenly have
a waking dream, a vivid
smell, a vivid insight,
some emotion.
So that was the first conclusive
demonstration that
thinking and feeling and your
senses are electrical as well.
From there the story
gets very weird.
In the 1960s, two scientists,
Jose Delgado and Robert Heath,
one of them, in fact, funded by
the CIA, did a variety of
experiments on animals and then
on humans to show that
they could control behavior
through electrical
stimulation.
With electrodes implanted in
the brain, they could put
animals to sleep or
wake them up.
They could make an animal hungry
or satiated, aggressive
or fearful.
With one experiment in a troop
of monkeys, they could change
which monkey was the alpha
male of the troop by
stimulating the right
parts of the brain.
Delgado, a Spanish scientist,
was quite a showman.
So he repeatedly did
this experiment.
This is him in a bull
ring in Cordoba.
Delgado is the guy
on the right.
He's got a cape.
And you could just barely see
he's got something with an
antenna here.
The bull has been worked up
by someone else before.
So the bull starts
to lean forward.
It's getting aggressive.
You could see more clearly, A,
there's something on the
bull's head, and B, this black
box with a long antenna.
The bull starts to charge him.
Delgado drops the cape and hits
the button on this radio
device that he has.
And the bull skids to a halt
because it's now terrified of
him, because he has remotely
stimulated an input of
electricity to its fear
centers in its brain.
I'm going to show you
a video of this.
This video is from the French
documentary in the 1960s.
So it's in French.
It's not exactly HD.
Delgado is the guy in
white who appears a
little bit into it.
And watch how the bull reacts
to him at various times.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAMEZ NAAM: That's the bull
running away from him.
He hits the button.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAMEZ NAAM: So Delgado went
on to write a book called
Physical Control of the Mind,
Towards a Psychocivilized
Society, where he posited that
we could improve society
dramatically by fitting
criminals with brain implants
that would cut off their
criminal urges, so on and so
on and so forth.
The medical community and
scientific community's
response to this
was that it was
extremely, extremely creepy.
And can we please stop all
that and head on to some
medical applications of this
tech, which they did.
There's a TV show called House
with a doctor called House
that solves all sorts of
crimes-- or all sorts of
medical riddles, I think.
Well the original Dr. House,
Dr. William House, was the
first person to find a real
medical use for this
technology.
He invented the cochlear
implant.
It looks like a hearing aid, but
it's for those people that
have no hair cells
in the inner ear.
So no hearing aid
can help them.
Instead what it does is it
picks up sound of the
microphone.
It has a small compute that
does a re-encoding, if you
will, from vibrations
into nerve impulses.
And then it electrically
stimulates the nerves of the
inner ear, the auditory
nerve fiber.
And that causes people
to hear.
The auditory nerve has 30,000
neurons in it on each side.
And the first cochlear implant
had one electrode.
The best ones implanted in
people today have 23.
So you wouldn't think it
could work at all.
But it actually produces hearing
that is not as good as
a normal person's, but is enough
that they can read--
can hear what people are
saying and interpret it
without reading lips.
And it has been life changing.
About 200,000 people around
the world have this today.
This is the picture an
eight-year-old girl hearing
for the first time.
And I'm going to show you a
video of an eight-month-old
boy who has just had his
cochlear implant
implanted and activated.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Here we go, turn it back on.
And he's back on again.
See how he turned?
-Hi Jonathan.
Hi.
Can you hear that?
Hi sweetie.
Could you hear that?
[LAUGHTER]
-Hi.
Hi.
-You've got that, Deb, right?
-Hi Jonathan.
Hi.
-We call that a late
Christmas present.
RAMEZ NAAM: So this is a life
changing technology.
Like I said, 200,000 people
around the world have it now.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAMEZ NAAM: This little boy
turned five in December and
he's still doing great.
Now I told you along the
requirements, we need to have
data input into the brain.
So I've just shown you proof of
principal of data input of
one data type, audio.
Now we all care about
our hearing.
It's very important to us.
Another sense we care about
a fair bit is sight.
So let's see data
input for sight.
This man, Jens Naumann, this
picture was on the cover of
Wired magazine in 2002.
Jens, when he was 18 years
old, worked on a railway.
And one day with his
pick he struck
something he got was rock.
It was steel.
A little fragment came up and
destroyed one of his eyes.
Lives in Canada, very active
fellow, refused to compromise
about his lifestyle.
The next year he was
out snowmobiling.
And part of the clutch had a
problem and threw a fragment
of metal that destroyed
his other eye.
And he was rendered blind
in both eyes.
He was blind for 20 years, until
2002 when this happened.
So what he's wearing is a CCD
camera, not that different
from any digital camera today.
The cable here goes to a small
computer that he wore on his
hip, actually it was about
this big back then.
And now it's probably the
size of a quarter.
And from there the signal is
translated from the format of
the camera to one that his
brain can understand.
And it travels back up into a
jack in the back of his head,
Matrix style.
Jens has this system which has
256 electrodes, as opposed to
the many billions of neurons in
his primary visual cortex.
So again, there's a huge
mismatch in the size of the
pipe to the size of the
system, if you will.
You wouldn't think it
could possibly work.
But if produces what they call
limited mobility vision.
What does limited mobility
vision mean?
Well, here's Jens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I was able to very carefully
drive and look from my left
side of my right side, making
sure I was between the row of
trees on the right and the
building on the left.
And when I got near any
obstruction in the front, I
would see that there
was an obstruction.
I would also see the lack
of obstructions.
And went I backed up, I would
be able to inspect for
instructions there.
It was really a nice feeling.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAMEZ NAAM: It was really
a nice feeling.
So that's a guy who was blind
for 20 years driving a Mustang
convertible.
Now Jens has terrible vision.
It's really, really atrocious.
I wasn't in that parking lot
with him and you probably
wouldn't want to be.
But it's a big step up from
zero vision whatsoever.
So that's data input.
And throughout--
in the novel, you see examples
of people getting video and
audio going straight
to their brain.
But what about data output?
Can we get output out of
the brain to control
systems or send data?
Well we can and we have.
So this is a doctor named Phil
Kennedy and a patient name
Johnny Ray.
Johnny Ray was 52 years old,
a Vietnam vet, drywall
contractor, played
blues guitar.
One day he had a
massive stroke.
He woke up in the VA hospital
in Atlanta, paralyzed
from his neck down.
And to save his life they
had to do an emergency
tracheotomy.
So he couldn't speak either.
His only way to communicate was
to blink his eyes once for
a no and twice for yes.
That was it.
This guy Kennedy had been
working in monkeys and had
demonstrated that he could put
a single electrode in a
monkey's motor cortex, the
part of their brain
responsible for motion, and
train them to move a cursor
around on a screen.
He applied to the FDA for
permission to do it in a human
patient for the first time.
They said yes, with
some conditions.
One of their conditions was
that he had to seal
the skull back up.
They didn't want wires running
in and out of the skull and
having a risk of an infection
getting into the brain.
So they made the system
wireless.
It actually sits inside
of his brain.
It gets power and data from a
cap that he wears, or from the
equipment near his
hospital bed.
Now this is the most extreme
case of this mismatch.
Because it's literally one
electrode in Jonny Ray's
brain, but more than a million
neurons in his motor cortex.
But that gave him enough control
to be able to type out
messages on an on-screen
keyboard, which is a dramatic
step up from just being able
to blink at people.
And this technology has gotten
better and better, and is in
more serious human trials now.
And in fact, a video came out
just a couple months ago of a
woman using this to do something
tat was very, very,
very important to her,
which was to
have her morning coffee.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You're watching the most
advanced brain machine
interface in action.
Kathy Hutchinson is paralyzed
and unable to speak.
But just by thinking, she's able
to control the movements
of this robotic arm, and drink
her morning coffee.
She's part of a pioneering study
run by researchers at
Brown University in the US.
-People who are paralyzed have
their brain disconnected from
their body.
So they're not able to--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAMEZ NAAM: So we've seen data
input now of video and audio.
We've seen data output
of motion.
And now in primates they have
data input as well.
They have systems like this that
also sent touch data back
into the brain.
There's one other domain that I
want to talk about, which is
Parkinson's, that I mentioned
early on.
All Parkinson's drugs
fail over time.
They just stop working
eventually.
But now we're finding that with
something called a deep
brain stimulator, a single
electrode run very deep into
the brain, you can keep a
Parkinson's patient healthy
and functional for
quite a while.
And there's 80,000 of
these that have been
implanted so far.
But interestingly enough,
they found some side
effects with these.
In some patients who got a deep
brain simulator who had
previously untreatable
depression, that wouldn't
respond to any drugs, they
suddenly had normal mood.
In some patients that had
previously untreatable OCD,
they found that suddenly they
had normal behavioral control.
And so now there are clinical
trials going on of using this
deep brain simulation for
depression and for OCD, both
of which seem to come
from very deep, old
portions of our brain.
Which, if you think about it,
is sort of the same sort of
work that Jose Delgado was doing
in his animal control,
but in a much more benign,
therapeutic sort of context.
So that's what's happening
so far in humans.
But what are the
opportunities?
And I did talk about this being
the science behind a
science fiction novel.
So it's not going to stop at
just this sort of thing.
The opportunities are really
in the higher functions, if
you will, memory, attention,
learning, the things that make
us really human.
In the film Memento,
Guy Pierce played
the character Lenny.
And Lenny can't form any
new long-term memories.
He will see something.
He'll learn it.
He understands it.
But within a few minutes, it's
gone from his memory.
This is an extreme case, but
cases like this and many, many
milder cases of this sort
exist in people who have
damage to part of their brain
called the hippocampus.
If your hippocampus is damaged,
you can't form these
new memories.
So working on this, scientists
have been trying to create an
artificial hippocampus, a
hippocampus chip that is
structured like the tissue in
the hippocampus, and that you
can shunt in.
So in a rat experiments, they
actually take a rat that has a
damaged hippocampus, this
area, and they put in
bypasses, arrays of electrodes
basically, that put in place
the hippocampus chip as a
replacement for the damaged
brain tissue.
And they found that they can
restore these rats' ability to
learn new things, restore
their memory, which is
awesome, has great application
for humans.
But they went farther
than that.
And they've show that they can
improve these rats' memories.
They can improve the speed
at which they learn.
They can keep the memories
around indefinitely because
there's no need for the memory
in a chip to decay.
And they can reactivate
that memory at will.
They can put the rat back in a
maze that it's learned and
reactivate the memory of that
maze's layout and have it have
perfect recall what was going
on inside of that and how to
find the water table or the
water platform at the end.
So that's the early glimmers
of work that would actually
potentially repair, and
maybe even improve,
human higher functions.
We've also gone into what
we would think of as
intelligence.
So in rhesus monkeys, people
have been working on a chip
that goes into the frontal
cortex, the most executive
part of your brain that
controls attention and
thoughts and juggling various
different things are going on.
So they take these
rhesus monkeys.
They put this implant in
their frontal cortex.
And they give them a monkey
IQ test, if you will.
It's called a pick and match
test where they have to learn
to match up certain
things together.
And while this is happening, the
implant learns the pattern
of what goes on in the neurons
of their frontal cortex when
they get it right and when
they get it wrong.
So then they take these monkeys
and they impair them
to get them to have a lower
score on the test.
They impair them by giving them
large doses of cocaine.
So the monkeys aren't
complaining.
They're pretty happy with the
experiment, I think, but their
scores actually do go down.
Then in half the monkeys, they
put the implant into an active
mode to see if it can
restore their skill.
And it can.
But it also goes farther
than that.
The average score of the group
that was not impaired or
enhanced was 75.
The group that had the implant
put into in active mode scored
on average an 85.
So they're actually using this
implant to improve the
monkey's skill on this monkey IQ
test, if you will, which of
course will lead to the cyborg
planet of the apes.
But the real frontier, I
think, isn't so much in
enhancing individual
capabilities, though that is
something that we will
actually look at.
It's really in communication.
Once upon a time, computers
were about solo work.
You had a computer because it
was a fancy word processor,
which really meant it was
a fancy typewriter.
It was a fancy spreadsheet
machine, which really meant
that it was a very fancy abacus,
in a certain sense.
But that's not what
actually changed
the world with computers.
What's changed the world has
been their ability to
communicate things between us,
and with the cloud overall.
And that's the direction that I
think is most exciting about
this sort of technology and the
direction that we really
go into in the novel.
There is some work happening
on that today.
DARPA is very interested in
all sorts of things that
improve human performance.
And they have a particular
program called the Enhanced
Battlefield Communication
Program.
And that program gave a grant
that funded this study.
This study had two monkeys
in different rooms, with
soundproofing between them,
wired together via implants in
their auditory cortices, so the
auditory part of the brain.
They would play a sound
for monkey one.
And what they found as they
hoped was that monkey two
could hear that sound and could
identify it, could say
what it was.
And DARPA's dream is to build
implants for soldiers where
the soldiers all have intuitive
knowledge of what's
happening to the other soldiers
in their squad and
the battlefield more broadly.
Real science happening,
not yet in humans.
We've also recently--
so now we've got motion
out of the brain.
We've got audio out
of the brain.
This is video out
In humans--
this study was done last year.
They put subjects in an fMRI
machine, a brain scanner.
It showed them a clip
from video.
And then an algorithm tried to
match that clip to what they
were actually seeing.
So tried to match their brain
activity to what they were
actually seeing.
Because it's techies here,
I can talk about it
a little bit more.
What they actually did was the
algorithm had a library of
fuzzed out video frames that it
could access, and a machine
learning model that learned
how to-- or was trained to
match up different patterns of
brain activity with the most
likely clip from its
video library.
And let's see how
it actually did.
Now this is very, very
early technology.
But you can see that just seeing
what's happening in the
patient's brain from the
outside, it gets some vague
idea of what it is that
they're looking at.
Which is exactly what
we'd expect.
In general in the brain, the
same neurons fire, the same
activity happens, when you're
seeing something, when you're
imagining that thing, and when
you're remembering that thing.
There's some difference in
higher order bits of the
brain, but in the primary visual
areas or the primary
auditory areas, it's the
same sort of thing.
All of this, by the way,
happened with brain scanners
on the outside.
And those are very, very
limited in how high the
resolution they can get
is of what's going
on inside the brain.
With actual electrodes in the
brain, this quality would
probably much, much higher.
And now the team funded by DARPA
that did the hippocampus
improvement for the rats is
looking at linking the
hippocampi of two rats together
and seeing what could
happen, seeing if one rat who's
been trained to run the
maze can convey that information
directly to
another rat that's never
seen the same maze.
Now like all experiments, the
first ones of this will almost
certainly fail, but we will
eventually get there.
That's the kind of thing that
people are working on now.
Then that leads, of course,
to Keanu Reeves
saying, I know kung fu.
Now let's talk practicality.
I've been spinning out what this
sci-fi world could look
like and it's really fun to play
with, but there are some
real limitations.
The first limitation
is quality.
Can any of you say what this
image is on the right?
If you've seen this example
before, please don't say.
Anybody who hasn't seen it,
can you pick this out?
Is it Jesus?
Is it the Statue of Liberty?
It could be both.
AUDIENCE: Woman with a hat.
RAMEZ NAAM: Woman with a hat.
Very good.
That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] put a hat
on the Statue of Liberty.
RAMEZ NAAM: On Jesus.
So Jens Naumann, the blind guy,
he has 256 electrodes.
He has a 16 by 16 pixel
display essentially.
This is the quality
of his vision.
So you can see why nobody wanted
to be in that parking
lot when he was driving
in the car.
He can basically see large
obstructions and not
much more than that.
So quality is a big
limitation.
And indeed, if you look at the
most sophisticated brain
computer interface we've ever
implanted in someone, has this
256 electrode situation
right now.
And that's largely because the
people who have been doing
this have been neurologists and
neuroscientists and not
electrical engineers.
That's not who've been
doing it so far.
But they are starting
to get into it.
And now you see labs devoted
entirely to developing the
hardware that's being used
in these experiments.
University of Michigan has 1,000
electrode wireless chip.
And a German company called
Infineon has a 16,000
electrode wireless chip
that's coming on the
market right now.
So we will see that
bandwidth go up.
And there's huge room
to improve.
The chip in my laptop has about
a billion transistors in
it in a size not much different
than some of these
interfaces.
Of course, these things are very
hot, but we don't have to
run them at gigahertz.
If you run them at 100 Hertz,
your going to pretty much
match what the brain can do.
So it's quite possible with
advanced technologies that we
already have in other domains
to dramatically increase the
bandwidth coming in and
out of the human
brain in these systems.
And we don't have to go far for
it to suddenly look pretty
functional in terms of restoring
functionality for
someone who's been impaired.
At 5,000 pixels, this is what
you see, which is a dramatic,
dramatic step up from 256.
And 5,000 pixels is still
dramatically smaller than the
type of technology that we use
in electronics traditionally.
The other very big limitation
is this is your brain we're
talking about.
Very few of us are going to
voluntarily have brain
surgery, certainly not to get
256 pixel vision, or even the
5,000 pixel vision.
So this is a very big hurdle.
In the book, I get around
this by saying, hey,
you swallow the drug.
The nanoparticles go through
your blood-brain barrier and
self assemble around
your neurons.
It's all great.
But that's not the technology
that we have today.
Of course there have been other
cases where we've gone
from something being so unsafe
and so impractical to being
very practical.
They used to say that
eye surgery would
never really take off.
Our eyes are pretty
precious to us.
Not quite as much as our brain,
but we don't trivially
mess with them.
But the excimer laser that made
Lasik possible changed
that game tremendously.
Before the excemer laser, there
were less than 20,000
eye surgeries done per
year in the US.
Now we're over two
million per year.
And the cost has gone down from
10s of thousands in the
distant past to a few hundred
dollars per eye right now,
depending on whether or not you
go with the very lowest
bidder on this.
Now is there an excimer laser
for brain surgery?
I don't think there's anything
quite that dramatic, but there
are technologies on the horizon
that are dramatically
simplifying and speeding
up brain surgery.
And the ones that I think
about are neurovascular
stereotactic surgery.
So what does that mean?
Neurovascular means they don't
cut open your skull, and
instead they get to the brain
via the bloodstream.
So they insert something into
normally the femoral artery,
and they can work this up.
This is actually a diagram
for heart surgery.
They could work it all the
way up into your brain.
And they've been doing this
for aneurysms for the last
several years.
It has dramatically reduced
the length of surgery, the
hospital stays, the cost,
and the risk.
Because cutting open your skull
is serious business.
The other part of this is what
we call stereotactic surgery,
which means that the probe is
being guided by magnets.
So it happens in a fancy-looking
operating room
like this, probably not quite
as clean and perfect,
hopefully with some doctors
in it as well.
But the doctors actually sit
at a terminal and use a
joystick to move the probe.
The probe itself has a camera
on it so they can see.
There's an imager that shows
them where it is on a
cross-section of the body.
And then the large device around
this person is using a
shifting magnetic field to pull
the probe along in the
direction the doctor wants to
go with the joystick, rather
than this clunky old cutting
and so on and so forth.
One of the real luminaries in
neuroscience, a guy by the
name of Rodolfo Llinas, who's
the editor of a journal called
Neuron, has proposed that we
could use this to build a very
advanced brain-computer
interface.
What he points out is that
nanotubes are essentially
excellent wires, and are
very, very, very small.
These aren't even nanotubes.
These are nanowires that are
much bigger than a nanotube,
but they're still very,
very, very small.
In fact, each of these is
about a quarter of the
diameter of the wavelength
of visible light.
Visible light is about 400-ish
nanometers, and these are
about 50 nanometers across.
These are so small that a bundle
of a million of them
would take up only about 1% of
the cross sectional area of
the smallest capillary
in your body.
So Llinas says, hey, let's stick
in a bundle of a million
of these, work it up into your
brain, and then use the
magnets to make it spread out
and touch a million different
neurons in your brain
all at once.
And he is starting to do animal
studies investigating
this technology.
And we'll see if that's a viable
path to dramatically
increase the bandwidth in
and out of the brain.
And this gets closer to the
technology of Nexis.
So those are the hardware
issues.
But let's talk about software.
Some of us work on
software, right?
We all know that software is
absolutely perfect, especially
Microsoft software.
I'll point at myself
a little bit here.
I've never seen this
screen myself.
I don't know, it's
a myth, I think.
But what does it mean if the
software running in your
brain, or even just the software
your brain is talking
to, suddenly crashes?
What does that mean if you
get malware or a virus?
That could be a little bit
more serious when it's
something running inside
your brain.
And in fact some of this
has been shown.
Anyone know who this is?
This is a fellow named
Barnaby Jack.
He's famous mostly for this hack
he did on the stage at
Black Hat I think in 2010, where
from across the stage,
he made this ATM just start
spewing out bills.
But lately Barnaby's been
interested in medical devices
and the security around them.
So in 2011 he did this hack.
What he's got in his hand is
a custom-built antenna,
essentially.
And what he's figured out that
he can do is that wirelessly,
he can discover any insulin pump
by Medtronic, the number
one manufacturer, within several
blocks of himself, can
sniff out their IDs, get root
access, and make them do
whatever he wants, including
pump out all 300 units of
insulin that they have inside of
them, which for a diabetic
would be lethal.
That was 2011.
In 2012, he did another hack
with a leading pacemaker model
where he demonstrated that in a
smaller range, within about
50 feet, he could cause it to
drop a 730-volt discharge into
the person wearing it, which
would also be lethal.
And in fact, do any of
you watch Homeland?
I'm going to give a spoiler, so
go la, la, la if you don't
want to hear this.
In a recent--
I don't watch the show, but
I'm told that in a recent
episode, they assassinated the
vice president by remotely
turning off his pacemaker.
And if you recall, Dick Cheney,
when he was vice
president, for quite a
while, had no pulse.
He was in continuous cardiac
failure and instead he had an
implanted pump that moved
his blood around.
I don't know what
APIs that had.
But science fiction sounds more
and more like real life.
So security is a very
big challenge.
That's one of the things that
the book gets into a little
bit, is what happens when people
can reroute your brain
or somebody else's.
But the biggest question I think
of all of the stuff, as
it comes to pass, as I think it
will, is what's the impact
on society?
So the printing press is very
old information technology and
it's had marvelous effects.
Let's talk about two effects.
It supercharged innovation.
By allowing ideas to spread from
person to person, it just
accelerated the rate of
invention, the rate of
knowledge dissemination.
And it didn't start
the Renaissance.
Some other things did.
But it really powered through,
and the scientific
revolution, and so on.
It also was a great tool of
anti-authoritarianism.
So it's famous, the first thing
printed on the printing
press was the Gutenberg Bible.
Definitely a tool of authority,
if you will.
One of the later things printed
on it was Martin
Luther's list of complaints
about the Catholic Church, his
pamphlets which he then nailed
to the doors of churches and
led to the creation of the
Protestant Church and the
erosion of power of the
Catholic Church.
It was also used to print the
Revolutionary pamphlets in the
late 1700s of the founding
fathers of this country.
So overall, information
technology has been a very
anti-authoritarian thing
in this context.
But it wasn't always so.
The very first information
technologies created by the
Sumerians and Egyptians
were in the hands
of a very few people.
And they more allowed for the
creation of empire and the
clamping down on the freedoms
of the individual than the
other way around, again, because
only a small minority
had access to and control over
and the ability to use this
technology.
So today we have that
conflict about
information tech currently.
During the Arab Spring, this
picture made its way around, I
think taken from a
place in Egypt.
Revolution tools, no longer
the AK-47, no longer the
machete, now Twitter
and Facebook.
And to a certain extent,
this is true.
Wael Ghonim, who was one of
the people behind the Arab
Spring, talks about how one of
the things that started this
was a video taken of police
beating up a student in
Alexandria, which was then
posted to YouTube and then
made its way onto Facebook.
And the first Arab
Spring protest--
in Egypt, anyway.
It was the second country.
But the first ones there were
organized as a protest about
this kid's beating, and it
was a Facebook event.
On the other hand, people will
tell you that in Iran, the
authorities have used Twitter
and Facebook to track down
people who are saying
anti-authoritarian things.
So we still have this big
question of to what extent and
in what situations will
information technology be used
as a tool of liberation versus
a tool of building
something like 1984.
And that's the question I think
I try to most get that
in hopefully a fun
way in the novel.
And I am an optimist.
I think that by and large, this
sort of technology, a
more intimate means of
communicating than ever
before, will be a hugely
positive thing for society.
But we have to be on the lookout
for and guard against
its possible abuses as well.
So that's it.
Thank you very much.
I think we have time
for questions.
And there's some books
outside that I'm
happy to sign for people.
AUDIENCE: I've read that one
of the problems with the
electrode connections is that
they degrade over time.
Has that gotten better
in recent years?
RAMEZ NAAM: Yeah, so it's
a very big question.
In some ways, we don't know.
So the brain doesn't like the
intrusion of electrodes.
It treats them as a
foreign object.
It tries to guard
against them.
It builds scar tissue.
So there's two frontiers
on that.
One is making electrodes
smaller
and smaller and smaller.
So the newest technologies of
nano probes are about 100
times smaller than
the current ones.
The other is what they call
bio-compatible materials that
won't break down.
And there's whole labs dedicated
to just that.
We're still not there yet,
partially because no one has
worn one of these things for
a very, very long time.
So in some ways, we don't see
what all the effects will be
after you've had one
for 20 or 30 years.
AUDIENCE: Would you like to make
some predictions for us?
RAMEZ NAAM: Oh my gosh,
predictions.
I'll make a couple
By 10 years from now, the first
people with bionic eyes
will be here.
In fact, it's probably
closer than that.
You're looking at about five
years for approval of the
retinal prosthesis.
And within 10 years, I'd say
there will be at least 100,000
people that have them.
In the next 10 years, the FDA
will start acquiring threat
modeling and security validation
of the software and
protocols on your devices.
There will be in the next 10
years the growth of a kind of
DIY hacking movement that wants
to hack their retinal
prostheses and their cochlear
implants and so on.
Those are a few.
AUDIENCE: Have people done stuff
outside the spectrum
that we normally see or hear?
RAMEZ NAAM: Not exactly, but it
is possible to do sort of
translation or shifting.
So it's totally possible to take
one sensory domain and
shift it to another.
So we could take infrared with
a rental prosthesis, pick it
up, and compress it into a very
bright red, for instance,
on the screen.
There's no obstacle to
that, really, at all.
And you can see that.
There's a brand new retinal
prosthesis that's being
experimented with that does
something very funky, actually.
So normally, the connections in
the retina aren't numerous
enough to give you the ability
to read, really.
So this does something else.
It picks up sight.
It spots Braille.
It sees Braille, and it
massively zooms the Braille,
effectively, and feeds that in
so that blind people can take
all of the books they already
have and actually look at them
and learn to read that way.
So there's all sorts of
domain shifting that
you can imagine doing.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
When do you think we'll
beat the bandwidth of
our eyes and ears?
RAMEZ NAAM: That's a really
good question.
When do we think we'll
be the bandwidth of
our eyes and ears.
I think it'll be a while,
to be honest.
As much as I write about this
and so on, progress on the
electronics goes very, very
fast, but you're always more
conservative when you're
doing trials on
humans or even on animals.
So I think it'll be on the
outside of that 10-year
spectrum, but probably not 20.
BRAD TEMPLETON: There's a friend
of mine who made a
smartphone app that remaps
the colors just
in the visual spectrum.
It doesn't go outside of the
visual spectrum, but it remaps
them so that they match more the
colorblind person's eyes.
So the colorblind people can
look through this and they can
now tell the difference between
the red and the green
in the way they can't tell
with their own eyes.
They can just hold up
their phone and say,
oh, now I see that.
That's kind of cool.
Any more questions?
Yeah,
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
about these neural implants
and learning.
I think in the book people
pick it up almost
instantaneously.
But what do you think about
learning or the ability for
somebody who's in their
50s to learn--
just to pick these things
up quickly.
Do you have to be young, old?
Is there any--
RAMEZ NAAM: It's a
good question.
It probably will be the
case that being
younger will be an advantage.
But we're also getting better
on the algorithm side.
And we're in that feedback
is vastly important.
So the first monkey experiments,
the monkey
couldn't actually see the
robot arm moving.
And it never occurred to them
this was very important.
So this was actually a very
famous monkey experiment where
the monkey sends its brain
signals over the internet to
robot arms 600 miles away, which
was a great gimmick, but
it couldn't see the
thing moving.
So it turns out that in most of
these systems, the learning
happens in both directions.
The system has to adapt.
It has to be calibrated,
usually
intentionally, for the person.
When they put in the brain
visual implant for Jens, they
spend time calibrating, like
learning what each pixel is,
effectively, on the grid.
And they just--
it goes into the software.
But it's also the case
that the brain
adapts to these things.
And it can adapt pretty
darn quickly.
And now Johnny Ray, the
paralyzed guy, it took them
about six months to train
him to use his
one electrode system.
Now they can get people working
pretty well in a
matter of several minutes.
It's fast enough-- they've done
some studies where they
have a brain implant for people
who are either testing
it or people who are having
surgery for other reasons,
usually epileptics having
oblation done.
They ask their permission
to do this, and
the people sign off.
They'll put the thing on the
surface of their brain during
the surgery, and they're have
them playing Pong with it now
within 15 minutes before taking
it off, in large part
because the algorithms that
are interpreting what's
happening have gotten
a lot better.
Which really means we've gotten
better understanding of
what the encoding is of these
data types, if you will,
inside the brain.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
RAMEZ NAAM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --books from, I don't
know, the '70s, '80s?
He was writing about people who
had brain implants that
stimulated their pleasure
centers, since they turn into
wire heads and sat and basically
had a cocaine high
continuously forever.
What do you see--
I mean obviously this could be
applied to mood and a variety
of things other than
just information.
What do you see happening
there and
how would it be regulated?
RAMEZ NAAM: Absolutely.
So in one of the early
experiments, those creepy
guys, Delgado and Heath,
they did some
very, very creepy things.
One of the things they did was
simulation of pleasure centers.
They used it in a couple ways.
They tried to switch a guy
from gay to straight.
By in a psych ward, they
put something in
his pleasure center.
They brought in a female
prostitute and then repeatedly
stimulated his pleasure
center.
It didn't work, but they
were thinking that way.
They gave another guy the
control over his pleasure
center, and found at some times
he would hit the button
1,500 times an hour,
which means about
once every two seconds.
But the ultimate control is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
slow or something?
RAMEZ NAAM: I think maybe he got
really blissed out for a
second and then he'd come
to and be like, oh yeah.
So the ultimate control is,
don't do the surgery to
implant the electrode there.
And I think that that will be
the medical ethical norm in
most of these cases.
But there are certainly
potentials for abuse.
And actually in the sequel to
Nexus, I show a character that
has a very serious problem
that's developed as a result
of maybe not having the implants
avoid certain areas.
AUDIENCE: I think--
I heard a technology called
transcranial magnetic
stimulation.
So that seems a little bit
safer, maybe, because it's
completely external.
So do you have any--
RAMEZ NAAM: With transcranial
magnetic stimulation, and now
with direct current cranial
stimulation, they've done some
interesting things.
With the magnetic stuff,
a lot of it has been--
well one group can make at
least some people have a
religious experience or
something like that by
stimulating the right areas.
And then with the electrical
stuff, they can also,
apparently, at least they're
claiming make people somewhat
autistic and have almost
savant-like
abilities appear in some.
It's kind of very early days.
You're not sure how much
you trust the research.
You want to see 5 or 10 papers
on something first.
With the direct current
simulation, something that
does look fairly repeatable
is that they can
speed learning time.
So they can maybe cut your
learning time on certain
things by 20% by running a very,
very mild current across
the top of your skull while
you're learning something.
So that looks pretty neat.
But it's not a technology that's
going to get you to
have, like video in or video
out or something like that.
BRAD TEMPLETON: The direct
current simulation actually
makes you more trusting, too.
You're more--
so I wanted, when I go into
negotiations now, I say, would
you mind wearing this hat
while we have this
negotiation?
Nobody wants to wear the hat.
Are we mostly done with
audience questions?
Matt has a question.
RAMEZ NAAM: Oh.
AUDIENCE: So what do we know
about the encoding?
With pixels, it's a linear
kind of thing.
In the brain, is
it logarithmic?
Is it linear?
How does that all?
RAMEZ NAAM: So it differs
by sense.
And the senses are going to be
a lot easier than the higher
functions because we can
kind of understand
what the coding means.
So in vision it is pretty much
spatial, in V1, the visual
area in the back of your head.
But it's spatial with
some caveats.
Things are not entirely
spatial.
It's kind of more spatial
if you took the grid and
flattened it.
But then your arms, of course,
are all kind of
squiggly and so on.
And then some neurons, they
are more including certain
colors, and more encoding
motion, so with those caveats.
And we kind of--
I wouldn't say there's a
formalism of that encoding.
It's just that we've gotten
better and better at having
code that can actually
translate that.
In audio, we think that
the encoding is
the frequency domain.
So as you shift from one region
to another, it gets
more and more towards
representation of higher and
higher frequencies.
In motion, it's more
complex than that.
But one thing that's nice in all
of these, like a general
characteristic we're finding
is that we can get good
results with very sparse
connections.
In any given region,
we're sampling a
very, very tiny bit.
So it's not a very
fragile protocol.
It's a very robust protocol
that just gets higher and
higher resolution as you
have access to more of
what's going on.
And there's other stuff we know
in the higher domains
even, we know some various
different things.
Like in parts of your brain, you
can trace the recognition
of different animals
through one
particular area of the brain.
And you can find very reliably
that the cat versus dog areas
are kind of separate and in
the same relationship
physically in different
people's brains.
And there's even weird studies
with taking monkeys, having
them look at pictures of a
cat, stimulating the dog
center, and getting them to
recognize it as a dog instead.
So there is very, very, very
funky stuff out there.
BRAD TEMPLETON: So there's a
physical difference between
cat people and dog
people then.
RAMEZ NAAM: I've never seen a
correlation of is that area
enlarged in one or the other,
but that would be a great
study, Brad.
Let's put in a grant.
BRAD TEMPLETON: That's right.
I want to ask about mind
control, because you love mind
control and it plays
a role in the book.
And not just, though, in forced
mind control, but the
concept of voluntary mind
control, people wanting to
change their attitudes,
people wanting to--
or socially pressured
to do so.
For example, there's a hormone
that makes some animals more
monogamous.
If that applied-- or a gene
therapy like that applied in
humans, you could see it being
part of the wedding vows.
Why won't you take this
treatment that makes you love
me forever, darling?
You love me, right?
What do you think about the
potential for mind control
from these?
RAMEZ NAAM: That's
the vasopressin
receptor gene, right?
Naked voles are one of the only
annals we found that's
really monogamous.
Yeah, I think people
will do it.
There was a time in my life
that I would have-- that I
felt like I was not very
outgoing or not very
adventurous.
And if I had an option to
change my dopamine DDR2
receptor and suddenly want to
go skydiving all the time, I
probably would have done it.
I might now.
So I think people will
voluntarily engage in
technologies that will allow
them to change their own
personalities all the time.
Or for that matter, I want
something that's going to get
me out of bed and to the
gym reliably every day.
It's better than a
workout buddy.
You've got a little app on your
brain that's like, up,
here we go.
AUDIENCE: So question
on that vein.
It's already bewildering
difficult to keep track of the
options we have in life, with
the internet and so forth.
So this is a future where
everybody has to understand
how the brain works and
what their options are
for changing it.
RAMEZ NAAM: Not necessarily.
I would say most people who use
apps and their phone don't
understand how their
phone works.
They have to have some
understanding of some
abstractions about the phone.
But they don't have to be
neuroscientists of the phone.
They don't have to be EEs
to know, like, oh, I
really like this app.
Or no, this kind of thing is
possible, they have to figure
out some things.
Like, eventually people really
need to understand, is the
data in the cloud or
on their machine?
Because someday they might
not have signal.
So they have to learn some
things about what's going on.
But they don't have to learn
all the deep details.
But I agree that the future gets
more and more bewildering
and that's a challenge.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if we know
anything about memory.
Like is there some way--
is any research into, like,
adding a hard drive to your
brain, basically?
Because you've talked a
lot about processors.
RAMEZ NAAM: That's what
people want to do.
I think it's going
to be tough.
We don't understand
a whole lot.
But just like with vision and
sound and motion, the way that
we've actually made progress on
the encoding is trying to
repair these things in people
that have some sort of damage.
So that's the most encouraging
thing about the rat study and
so on, is that doing the work to
try to fix the damage will
functionally teach us more and
more about the encoding.
But today I'd say we
know relatively
little, to be honest.
BRAD TEMPLETON: We used to
know more yesterday.
RAMEZ NAAM: It's possible,
some of us.
AUDIENCE: How does this change
your ideas about death?
And what do you--
let's say we build AI machines
in the future.
How do we deal with the problem
that our biological
bodies are going to die?
RAMEZ NAAM: Well it's not really
exactly in this domain.
But I guess it's a large
extension of it, is I believe
uploading is possible.
Everything we know says that if
you had a complete map of
your brain down to the molecular
level, at least, and
we could simulate it,
we'd have a copy of
your thoughts running.
We don't know how technically
difficult it is.
You can make a guess.
You can say, oh, if we get it
at the level of neurons and
synapses, that's probably
good enough.
We don't know.
We won't know until we get
there and try it, to be
totally honest.
So I think eventually
technology
will make that possible.
Ray Kurzweil thinks it's going
to be 30 years from now.
It might be 100 years
from now.
It might be 1,000 years now.
But the brain is just another
information processor, a very
messy one, a very
interesting one.
And it's really, the pattern
of information is you, to a
certain extent.
So we can eventually
decouple those.
Just exactly when is still
a very open questions.
AUDIENCE: Would you feel
like that was you?
RAMEZ NAAM: That copy of me
would feel that it was me.
That copy of me would remember
it being me right here
answering this question, and be
like, oh, I feel like me.
And the other copy of me would
eventually be dead.
So now, what if that copy
made 1,000 more copies?
Would they all feel like me?
Yes.
We will have to-- here's the
philosophical thing I'll say.
Right now, if I'll use computer
lingo a little bit,
we don't differentiate, when we
talk about me, between the
class and the instance
of the class.
So eventually our conception
of personhood will change.
And we'll see, like, do you
believe that all other objects
that are of your class
are the same as you?
In some ways, yes.
And we'll start to make
that differentiation.
But we're not ready
for that yet.
Most philosophers don't have an
object-oriented programming
background, so we're not
quite ready for that.
BRAD TEMPLETON: Well thanks
a lot, Mez, for coming in.
RAMEZ NAAM: Awesome.
Thank you all.